automatiser une usine industrielle à
partir de plusieurs types d'équipements
l'activité de l'entreprise américaine
rockwell automation des systèmes de plus
en plus digitalisées notamment avec cet
outil destiné à gérer toute une usine
d'incinération et de revalorisation
d'ordures ménagères
c'est un système qui est heureux d'en
haut niveau matériel qui en cas de panne
matérielle type disque dur ou mémoire ou
cartes mères permettent la disponibilité
du système
de continuer à fonctionner coté à la
bourse de new york avec un chiffre
d'affaires de 6,7 milliards de dollars
au coût et l'automation a installé sa
filiale française à voisins le
bretonneux leader mondial dans son
secteur d'activité elle bascule
aujourd'hui vers l'industrie 4.0 c'est
un paquet d'informations qui a passé de
lusine jusqu'au sommet de l'entreprise
ce qu'on appelle les erp et cetera pour
diffuser ses informations et données in
fine et la bonne information à la bonne
personne au bon moment pour prendre les
bonnes décisions au niveau 2
de la gestion de lusine et donc de la
productivité des usines même
transformation pour l'alliance renault
nissan lusine automobile du futur se
construit au technocentre de guyancourt
plusieurs nouveaux outils automatiques
pour améliorer la productivité avec
notamment des robots collaboratif qui on
va venir voir ces les coutures sont bien
placés le contrôle après on va voir si à
l'instar de l'apport qu'on allait les
bons caractère qui sont sur les poignets
l'industrie se transforment et évoluent
sur saint quentin en yvelines
l'agglomération a obtenu en novembre
la reconnaissance territoire d'industrie
par le ministère de l'économie et des
finances